[Música]
i
hola y bienvenidos a europa hoy el
programa de actualidad europea de france
24 en español yo soy este dakar o desde
el parlamento europeo en bruselas es un
placer saludarles las tensiones con
rusia por su presión en la frontera con
ucrania preocupan desde hace semanas a
la unión europea y al mundo tanto la
otan como bruselas han alertado que
ahora mismo la situación es más tensa
que nunca volverá a rusia a invadir
ucrania que está en juego ahora mismo
para la unión europea antes de pasar al
debate hacemos un repaso a las
complicadas relaciones que han mantenido
rusia y la unión europea en los últimos
años
las relaciones entre rusia y europa se
encuentran en su punto más complicado
desde 2014 debido a la creciente tensión
que se vive entre moscú y ucrania en
1994 la unión europea y rusia firmaron
un acuerdo de asociación y cooperación
pero con la llegada de vladimir putin al
kremlin el 2000 poco a poco esta
relación se ha ido deteriorando
primero con la invasión de georgia en
2008 y luego la anexión de crimea en
2014 y la guerra en la región ucraniana
del donbass el papel de rusia en
conflictos como el de siria y libia el
apoyo al régimen de belarús los
ciberataques y la expansión de campañas
de desinformación desde moscú contra
occidente no han hecho más que elevar
las tensiones
también ha aumentado el descontento de
la posibilidad que rusia no haya
descartado un despliegue militar en
venezuela o cuba una amenaza que
recuerda a otros tiempos más propios de
la guerra fría
ahora todo el mundo está pendiente de
las decenas de soldados y tanques
parados en la frontera en ucrania
preparados para volver a atacar y
presionar a occidente tanto eeuu como la
otan han prometido a la unión europea de
tenerlos en cuenta en cualquier decisión
más aún si se decide sancionar a moscú
lo que tendría evidentes consecuencias
económicas también para las capitales
europeas y para poner un poco de
contexto la situación entre europa y
rusia y los últimos acontecimientos que
han ocurrido con nosotros tenemos a los
eurodiputados
javier nart del grupo renovar europa
bienvenidos javier un título histórico y
también a nacho sánchez amor del grupo
socialdemócrata gracias nacho graciosos
me gustaría empezar de todo con javier
llevamos semanas hablando de la amenaza
que puede suponer una nueva invasión de
rusia a ucrania sabemos que han
aumentado las tropas en la frontera pero
hasta qué punto podemos hablar de un
ataque inminente se podría tratar
incluso de una estrategia de vladimir
putin vamos a ver el despliegue que
tiene putin es un despliegue que excede
una amenaza pero en la entrada en
combate la de la invasión de ucrania es
absolutamente disparatada significaría
incluso para rusia un absoluto desastre
en consecuencia lo que está haciendo
putin es tratar de recuperar aquel vamos
a decir fondo estratégico y además
histórico en ruso que significó tanto
bielorrusia como ucrania y eso dentro de
unas garantías de la no expansión de la
otan hacia ucrania lo cual debe
entenderse como una parte de lo que son
las líneas rojas estratégicas de una
superpotencia nuclear como es social
y es que tener una nueva guerra fría a
nacho se que se impongan las nuevas
esferas de influencia no se han
descartado ni siquiera misiles en
venezuela o en cuba y yo creo que en el
fondo político porque a veces hablamos
mucho del último movimiento militar o
diplomático y yo creo que hay que para
que entienda a la audiencia de lo que
estamos hablando hay que volver a esa
lógica de que rusia está pretendiendo
que los países que son soberanos desde
muchos años dejen de hacerlo y admitamos
los demás que el uso tiene algún tipo de
derecho de veto sobre esa soberanía los
cuales efectivamente reconstruir las
esferas de influencia que tuvimos en la
guerra fría yo creo que esa lógica hay
que intentar impedir la rusia de
firmantes los acuerdos de helsinki rusa
y firmantes acuerdos que les garantizan
a todos los países su derecho a decidir
sus alianzas militares y de seguridad y
los hay que hacer es respetar ese
derecho en cualquier caso tanto en rusia
como en ucrania déjame decirte una cosa
al respecto
rusia económicamente tiene el pib de
españa
tenemos que comprender que cualquier
esfuerzo militar significa un esfuerzo
económico
la sobre extensión de lo que es el poder
militar ruso le crea limitaciones
importantes el espantajo de venezuela o
de cuba no tiene sentido excepto que
creen haya facilidades navales en el
sentido de grupos electrógenos para dar
electricidad a los submarinos
diesel-eléctricos que tienen y poco más
hay que recordar que tuvieron que
retirar la base de escucha que tenían en
lourdes en frente de las costas
norteamericanas porque carecía de
sentido incluso el económico hay aquí un
planteamiento un poco de juego de poker
el problema del juego de poker es que
estamos hablando de superpotencias y
carros de combate en la frontera
justamente estamos hablando de estas
esferas de influencia pero qué ocurre si
realmente rusia acaba invadiendo ucrania
puede tener también graves implicaciones
para la unión europea se están hablando
de duras sanciones está preparada europa
en plena recuperación económica de las
graves implicaciones que esto puede
tener es una pregunta que me gustaría
tener para los 2 nacho
tenemos que estarlo esta es una prueba
más de que estamos dejando la
adolescencia diplomática y entramos a la
de adultas lo cual supone desde luego
manejarse ya no solo con software sino
tener recursos de los que borra el
llamaba el aprender el lenguaje del
poder yo creo que en este este punto de
vista de las posibles repercusiones de
la acción rusa es bueno que vayamos de
la mano de eeuu y el resto del mundo
occidental las democracias directas
están sufriendo una grave erosión por
regímenes y liberales y este tipo de
esferas de influencia de las que
hablábamos yo creo que este es un buen
momento ojalá nunca llegue para
demostrar que estamos preparados y que
hemos aprendido algo al menos de esa
gramática y de ese lenguaje del poder yo
creo que si rusia invade ucrania y hay
que hablar de qué tipo de invasión así
cuál entrar con mucha fuerza central por
la zona ahora sé cesionista con algunas
unidades pero en cualquier caso el
mensaje político está mandado y creo que
hay que retirarlos del parlamento
europeo las consecuencias para rusia
serán gravísimas y masivas lo hecho
tiene razón pero hay una cuestión que es
importante la capacidad de sufrimiento
europa ha sido definida por rusia y
lamentablemente estoy de acuerdo como un
supermercado global en la capacidad de
sufrimiento de aceptar el sufrimiento
que tiene europa no tiene nada que ver
con el de rusia donde los rusos están
acostumbrados a apretarse el cinturón y
más en condiciones vamos a decir de
orgullo nacional orgullo nacional
humillado por la pérdida de territorios
históricos que son parte de rusia rusia
no se entiende es en ucrania y rusia
nace en la rush de kiev esto es la
realidad y en consecuencia es algo que
hay que entender el problema no es el
impacto el problema es la capacidad de
soportar el impacto en el tema del gas
que es donde hay un tema esencial españa
juega un rol fundamental porque españa
es el país que tiene la mejor y mayor
concentración de puertos con capacidad
de desembarco gasístico y de almacenaje
esto es otra cuestión importante yo
cuando contemplo un fenómeno militar no
me quedo en la al baraka o en la
alharaca de carros de combate ruidos
soldados cascos y kalashnikovs veo la
logística y veo la economía sin
logística y circo en economía no hay y
lo que ha dicho nacho yo estoy de
acuerdo posiblemente si hay alguna
acción militar rusa para calentar el
tema y decir ojo eso será a través de
tonos y luján donde no serán los rusos
siendo los rusos y en consecuencia se
despliegue que tienen bloquea fuerzas
ucranianas y debilita una respuesta en
el frente oriental
se están hablando de posibles sanciones
de por ejemplo el sistema de
transferencia swift que es el más
utilizado en el mundo o también uno de
los temas es el gasoducto nord stream 2
que se encuentra que bombear a gas
directamente hacia alemania ahora mismo
está paralizado se puede sancionar ya la
vez tener un gasoducto como el nuestro
en dos que hay que hacer en esta
situación
todos hemos advertido a alemania de la
dependencia política que le creaba esa
dependencia energética y yo tiendo a
entender que las razones de las manías
son lógicas desde ese punto de vista
pero llega un momento en que uno cuando
se le obliga a tener que decidir
al final tiene que hacerlo y yo creo que
esas llamadas a la no dependencia que
hemos hecho frecuentemente desde
bruselas los socios las instituciones
europeas al final muestran que como ha
pasado recientemente y kazajistán rusia
no ofrece ventajas económicas sí que eso
sirve una agenda política detrás y eso
tiene un coste para la unión europea y
para alemania alemania en contra de lo
que se está diciendo hoy lo comentábamos
con un colega no ha abandonado la unión
o la unidad que tenemos en la unión
europea frente a la amenaza rusa pero es
verdad que su lógica política el propio
hecho de que la mitad del país fue otro
país no hace tanto tiempo en la órbita
soviética condiciona la respuesta
alemana pero yo no quiero dibujar
alemania como alguien que está fuera del
consenso alemán están dentro del
consenso la línea europea en frente al
amenaza rusa es verdad cada uno aquí
tiene sus peculiaridades
bueno el rusia ha tenido un incremento
importante de divisas como consecuencia
del incremento de los precios del gas la
dependencia energética que planteaba
nacho en la que estoy absolutamente de
acuerdo la dependencia energética
significa una dependencia estratégica y
en consecuencia creo que alemania debe
entender que debe diversificar sus
fuentes de suministro de energía el
problema es que la alternativa que
básicamente es qatar es de muy difícil
conclusión porque qatar tiene unos
contratos muy importantes que bloquean
colapsan la mayor parte de su petróleo
hacia china eso crea un problema
lo que europa debe entender es que
tenemos un vecino y rusia- también debe
entenderlo el problema de rusia no está
con europa el problema estratégico de
rusia se llama siberia donde el
vacío demográfico y económico está
amenazado directamente por un lleno
demográfico y económico chino yo
recuerdo que hace unos pocos días el
ministro de defensa ruso dijo con mucho
sentido que rusia debería crear ciudades
de millones de habitantes en toda la
frontera con china eso es una definición
estratégica el problema es que yo creo
que occidente no ha tenido la
sensibilidad para entender las
necesidades estratégicas de rusia sin
que ello signifique una disminución de
las nuestras y rusia las tiene yo lo que
diría y concluyó sobre el tema de la
entrada de georgia y de ucrania en la
otan es que no hace falta dar ninguna
garantía la otan jamás podrá admitir a
ucrania y a georgia porque si las admite
lo primero que tiene que hacer es
declarar la guerra a rusia ya que crimea
está invadida por rusia
en aplicación del tratado de defensa
automática de cualquier ración de la
unión de la nato que esté amenazada o
atacada por otro país deberíamos entrar
tanto en georgia como ucrania en
consecuencia yo creo que putin ha
sobreactuado que es prisionero de sus
palabras y que tampoco occidente ha
tenido la sensibilidad de entender la
sensibilidad de los otros como
entendemos las nuestras pero siempre hay
que ponerse en la silla de la otra parte
para entender cuáles son los límites el
jefe de la diplomacia europea para
acabar asegura que lo que pretende rusia
es dividir a la unión europea negociando
directamente con washington y con la
otan moscú está consiguiendo su objetivo
no yo no lo creo aparentemente todas las
líneas de discurso de declaraciones eeuu
otra unión europea están exactamente en
la misma línea no veo no veo esa
división otra cosa es que rusia siempre
ha intentado eso no es ninguna novedad y
siempre que la unión europea se
convierte en un actor internacional
lo que pretende es explorar las posibles
divisiones en un bloque que no es un
estado y ellos juegan a considerar que
no siendo un estado en europea es fácil
de dividir y hay muchos aspectos los que
esto no ha sido así el presi entre otros
también se esperaba una división de los
socios no fue así y yo creo que rusia
está esperando eso en vano yo no veo
sinceramente aunque puede haber matices
lógicamente no veo una diferencia en el
discurso político entre eeuu la nato y
la unión europea muchísimas gracias a
esto ha sido todo por hoy muchísimas
gracias por este interés evidentemente
interesante debate nacho javier y a
ustedes os esperamos en el próximo
programa de europa hoy gracias por ver
france24 en español
[Música]